the gtx 1080 is down to $450 again and
this time it doesn't even have a sale
end date as a result GPU classes are
only bound to go down even lower so
don't buy yet welcome to Haris hobbies
so before we go any further I want to
make it completely clear that these
deals are really not as limited as it
may seem even just right now there is a
gigabyte card a so tech cart and EVGA
card available for 450 dollars the EVGA
card doesn't even have an end date the
gigabyte card has six days of the sale
and the DOE Tech card has four days
there was also an EVGA for the wind card
but that is now currently out of stock
and there are multiple other 1080s in
the four 60s and four 70s so even if the
current $400 deals end they'll
definitely be other 10 80s that will
come to take its place because this is
not just a random price drop this is
actually a trend towards $450 for the
past several weeks the GTX 280 has been
hovering in the low five hundred or 500
hour range but as the release day of the
gtx 1180 is getting closer the gtx 1080
is dropping towards $450 as a result
even if the current formal ngrams
retailer deals on the gtx to an 80 end
there will definitely be other GTI
Canadians to take its place at $400 over
the next couple of weeks so there's
really nothing to lose out on by waiting
a little bit longer now with that out of
the way GPU prices are going to drop
even lower and here's why first of all
the reveal of the gtx 1180 is
approaching very quickly on August 20th
right now many uninformed or skeptical
buyers are going with 10 series because
they don't know about the 11 series or
don't think they'll be coming very soon
but if the eleventh series launches
official by Nvidia then everyone will
know that it's going to come out very
soon and sales for the 10 series will
significantly slow down instantly
as a result retailers will have to offer
even bigger deals in order to maintain
their sales but if they have a lot of
accident
to get rid of as soon as possible the
release of the gtx 1180 may do nothing
to 10 series sales because of how it
unreachable for most people but what
their release Elmore mid-level cars like
the GTX 1160 and 1170 the sales for
tensors will definitely slow down for
example the GTX 1170 will pretty much
have the same amount of performance as a
GTX 980 actually probably a little bit
better but it will mostly come in at
little bit cheaper than what the GTX
1080 is at right now so why would
anybody go and buy a GTX 280 when they
can get the newest tech with better
performance for a cheaper price I know a
lot of you guys are like NB a-- is going
to price the eleventh series higher than
the ten series for it still makes sense
to buy the ten series but here's the
thing NVIDIA has already sold all their
attempt series cards to retailers and it
really isn't their problem anymore
currently it is a retailer's problem to
sell all those XS 10 Series GPUs and so
Vidya is not going to jack up the price
of the 11 series which will not only
slow down sales of the 11 series but
also make themselves look really greedy
now granted there may be a little
premium for the new tech such as GTD or
six memory for example the gtx 1070
costs of $380 at MSRP and so the gtx
1170 may cost four hundred or four
hundred and thirty dollars but I really
doubt that it's going to be $50 more
than the MSRP of the gtx 1070 so really
a maximum of four hundred and thirty
dollars
so really the gtx 1170 is going to be in
the low 400 and no one is going to buy
the gtx 1080 unless it doesn't lock
cheaper at $400 or the high 300s just
about everyone will spend an extra $20
to get the newest attack so really the
gtx 1080 would have to be in that height
300 for it to even make sense for the
value buyers so really that is where the
price of the GT X 1080 are heading so
don't buy a GTX 1080 right now pleaser
is still quite a drop to go and that
takes me on to my next point which that
you should really give a strong
consideration to the GTX of 1100 series
because even though there are really
huge discounts on that 10 series the 11
Series equivalents
cost just a little bit more but they
give you more performance you get to be
on the 22-metre architecture and you
even get GTD our six memories Plus who
doesn't like having the newest
technology available really the only
drawback to the GTX 1100 series over the
10 series is that really only the finest
edition cards will be offered for that
price the third-party variants are about
to be a little bit more expensive so
that it does increase the price gap a
little bit more so if you get 1100
series card when it launches you may
have to spend a 5200 on extra over the
10 series equivalent but the eleventh
series does come with a handful of nice
features so it's definitely worth on
consideration so overall there are some
great discounts on a 10 series right now
but really we don't only half way
through and there's a lot more discounts
to come so don't buy a 10 series card
just yet but really in any case I just
recommend that all of you guys wait for
the 1100 series because of how close is
it is good to know all of your options
before you buy because after the launch
of the 11 nurseries you're really just
bound to save even more money or get the
newest tech available so there's really
no loss so really we are almost there so
please don't make a decision that you
may regret after all of this time and
make that whole weight worth it but
that's pretty much all I have for you
guys this time so how do you guys feel
about this how low do you think GTX 10
series cars will go and which series do
you think is more worth it make sure
comment down below what you guys think
because I do real my comments and be
curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like together and make sure
drop a like and consider subscribing if
you like to see more videos like this
one but until next time this is Hari
I'll see you guys on the next one